وبعوده الى الضربات الامريكيه البريطانيه
الليله الماضيه شرقي الصعده في اليمن انضم
الينا من صنعاء مرسل الجزيره محمد العطاب
اهلا بك محمد اذا تفاصيل اكثر حول الاثار
اثار هذه الضربات الامريكيه
بالامس نعم ما يخص استهداف الطيران
التحالف البريطاني الامريكي منطقه شرقيه
مدينه صعده لا نستطيع ان نجزم ما هو
بالضبط الي تم استهدافه فهذه المنطقه اص
اصبحت من المناطق التي لابد ان تكون ضمن
خطه اي جديد لعمليات القصف في التحالف
الثنائي و تاتي هذه العمليه بعد استهداف
ايضا منطقه الكثيب بمدينه الحديده بعده
غارات متتاليه نتج عنها سماع انفجارات
وتصاعد اعمده دخان واكدت ايضا القياده
المركزيه الامريكيه انها استهدفت زورقين
كانا يشكلان حسب تصريحها خطرا على القطع
البحريه ونقلا عن رويترز عن شركه امبري
للامن البحري قالت بانه تعرضت سفينه تحن
بريطانيه لاضرار جراء هجوم بمسيره غربيه
الحديده وتؤكد مصادر الملاحيه ان السفينه
لم تستجب لنداءات بحريه اطلقتها جماعه
انصار الله ومطالبتها للعوده من حيث اتت
وتعد هذه العمليه الاولى والتي من المحتمل
ان يؤكدها الناطق العسكري باسم جماعه
انصار الله بعد ان شن التحالف الامريكي
البريطاني اكثر من 70 غاره خلال ما يقارب
72 ساعه وكانت وتيرتها وكانت وتيرتها خلال
الساعات الماضيه هي الاقل وكان اعلى وتيره
لها قبل يومين باجمال 48 غاره وفي الوقت
ذاته قال نائب وزير الخارجيه في حكومه
انصار الله في مؤتمر صحفي الصحفي عق
البارحه بان امريكا التي تتهم جماعته
بتهديد الملاحه البحريه هي نفسها التي
قالت بانها لا تتوفر معلومات ولا دلائل
على ان الكيان الاسرائيلي يرتكب يرتكب
مجازره بحق المدنيين في غزه واوضح العزي
ان الملاحه امنه في البحر الاحمر مشددا
على ان استهداف السفن الامريكيه
والبريطانيه جاء ردا على ما وصفه بالعدوان
على اليمن واتهم ايضا امريكا وبريطانيا
بعسكره البحر الاحمر مؤكدا ان الهدف هو
فقط منع السفن الاسرائيليه حتى ما وصفه
وقف العدوان على غزه وفي وقت سابق اكد
الناطق الرسمي باسم جماعه انصار انه ليس
من السهل تدمير القدرات العسكريه التابعه
للجماعه مشيرا الى انها اعيد بناؤها في ظل
سنوات الحرب التي وصفها بانها كانت قاسيه
وان ما وصفها بالغارات العدوانيه سواء على
اليمن او على العراق وسوريا قال بانها
ستزيد من كراهيه الشعوب وتوحدها ضد ما
اسماه بالوجود الاستعماري الامريكي في
المنطقه شكرا لك محمد العطاب مراسل
الجزيره كنت معنا من
صنعاء